[Musique]
au musée des arts décoratifs patrick
valberg nous invite à fêter le
cinquantenaire du surréalisme
plus
en 1922 à paris n'est c'est un grand
mouvement qui allait s'étendre au monde
entier et dans l' influence allaient
être décisives dans les arts et la
poésie
andré breton et ses amis entreprennent
une véritable révolution
ils veulent tenter une complète
libération de l'esprit redonner toute
son importance au rêve et à
l'inconscient ils veulent tenter
l'impossible et braver les interdits
créer de nouveaux rapports entre les
hommes
[Musique]
andré breton dira à propos du
surréalisme c'est prendre une conscience
toujours plus net et en même temps plus
passionnés du monde sensible
[Musique]
où
autour de lui paul eluard benjamin péret
philippe soupault jacques prévert que
nous point et chats robert desnos zara
antonin artaud michel leiris et bien
d'autres programmes la toute puissance
de l'imagination
[Musique]
e
ce mouvement fait condom et s'étendant à
tous les gens de création rassemblera
les plus grands noms de la peinture
contemporaine une oeuvre d'art digne de
ce nom
ra andré breton et celle qui nous fait
retrouver la fraîcheur des motions de
l'enfance elle ne le peut qu à la
condition expresse de ne pas tabler sur
l'histoire en cours dont la résonance
profonde dans le coeur de l'homme ne
doit être attendue que du retour
systématique à la fiction
[Musique]
on
cette exposition réunit des oeuvres de
man ray max ernst
miro salvador dali andré masson picasso
yves tanguy picabia victor brauner
quirico giacometti dominguez leonor fini
calder magritte paul delvaux
et nous ne vous laisserons pas tous
[Musique]
cette exposition exprime aussi toute la
reconnaissance que nous ressentons pour
andré breton
[Musique]